history will be made and i will become
the first independent mayor of
washington d.c
rodney grant
also known as red grant is one of the
most underrated comedians in the game
with almost 30 years of experience it's
always that one girl save your life look
like your friend about to throw up
he has performed on hbo comedy central
mtv and worked with the biggest names in
the game like cat williams snoop dogg
and other celebrities he's also starting
movies like american hustle and first
sunday
gonna have to come and get off the
crossings
however his passion for the world of
entertainment inspired him to start his
own production company in 2000 where he
has written and produced several films
his first being family reunion red was
born and raised in washington dc where
he has now chosen a new path to become
the mayor of washington dc we sat down
with him to talk about his early comedy
struggles it was just nothing that i can
do to come back from that boot current
comedy fame the emotional decision to
retire from comedy also what's wrong
with the current political system and
how he plans to change it rodney red
grant welcome to the show my friend i
would say that probably was one of the
best intros
of me
in a long time what
my man i'm gonna tell you why because
you actually
hit every point from the beginning even
the getting kicked out of school at 19
and coming home and you know not knowing
where i was going to be in life started
working at a
car dealership and
a friend said man you're funny you
should get on stage
and at that time i'm like
who would want to
get on stage and make people laugh
after what i just went through and it
was like god was just like telling me
hey
i'm going to change your spirit so you
can change other people's spirits
so that i appreciate that great uh intro
of course yeah you went to mr henry's
the open mind there i did i went to mr
henry's it was my first time on stage i
talked about
probably the worst i don't know i didn't
get i didn't get booed
but i didn't really get the last that i
thought i was going to get the first
time and i was talking about
wonder woman
couldn't come to my neighborhood because
her
uh somebody would shoot her uh braces
off or it was some co it was
it was it was genius at the time but it
was corny as heck my delivery uh and
when i got back in the car my my friend
named rob pearson
he uh
who actually told me to go on stage
he said
man why are you not talking about that
stuff that we talk about in the house
i was like what you mean he said you got
to talk about your family
you got to talk about your experiences
the things you're going through you
can't be talking about wonder woman and
then snap right there i was like
let me talk about my mom's let me talk
about my kid let me talk about my uh my
neighborhood my family you know and the
rest is history
so when you
because i watched your show last night
and it's always fun every time i've seen
you it always looks like you're having
fun up there and it's so natural but
when you're like all right let me go
from wonder woman to my personal stuff
do you like put pen to pad or have you
always just been on stage just like no
i'm a writer yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a
writer i take like writing really
serious
um
i think it's super important to be able
to write
because it allows you to express the
natural things that are going on in your
head i think people it actually
will help
people with mental health issues and
everything to be able to get your
uh the things out of your head onto
paper and express yourself a lot of
times people don't express themselves so
i actually just take a subject you know
i you can look my phone is like all kind
of this joke out the joke at the joke
and stuff that i probably would never
even talk about like i probably wouldn't
even be able to get to the jokes that
i've written it's so many but i take it
super serious and um you know my
teachers one of my teachers not all of
them but one of my teachers told me that
i wouldn't be a great writer
and
i went to savannah state when i went
there i
they they make you take these tests to
see what classes you're going to be in
and my writing skills were terrible so
they put me in like one of the lowest
like writing classes but what happened
was that teacher taught me how to write
essays
and once i learned how to write an essay
i understood that everything in life has
a beginning
has a middle it has an end
and all of the things i've written in my
life start with that structure
of writing essays so if you have like a
life experience or something about a
family member
it's an experience you have how do you
then like work it to translate to the
stage all right so my daughter
um
is 13
and i have another daughter
um
that's
and another one that's
33 or something uh around that eighties
um but they all three of them when i
when i talk about them
i set it up especially the
thirteen-year-old cause she's like
at home right now and she's
you know she's giving you that 13 year
old energy
and
you know she thinks she's smarter than
me in real life she does she thinks
she's smarter than me so that's what i
would write down first my daughter
thinks she's smarter than me
and then i will go and talk about all of
the things that she does that she thinks
is smarter than me
and to me you know yeah she she's smart
but she's still working on her common
sense
and
as as you grow and you learn more you
develop more common sense
you know so
you know as you know when you when
you're 13 year old
your common sense is what you're dealing
with
and she doesn't have any idea of what is
in store that she's going to gain so
much more common sense so you know i
just i write from my wife
you know
my wife always talks about like
she never laughs at the joke so that's i
say mine neither yeah i mean she never
like i i set it up so sweet
like i got a new joke about you
and i said it i'm so sweet and she's
always like okay let me hear it and when
i said say it she's always like
when she doesn't laugh that's when i
know it's going to be fun
say what they do
i'm doing it she didn't laugh yeah yeah
so yeah
so i mean you know i just go from that
perspective you know talking about my
mom's and my pops
yeah you write it down and then take it
to the stage and work it out i'm a
storyteller mm-hmm you know some
comedians they they write like okay well
i'm gonna i'm hutch you're gonna punch
no i'm like i gotta go um
okay we're going through this whole
journey this story
and we'll go through the story
until it crescendos to a end and then
i'll go
and i'll
take it to another store that's what i
noticed watching you last night was like
you can take a single topic it could
just be like the like that that topic of
getting like feeling sick when you drink
too much and you it was like 10 minutes
and it was all these act out you're all
over the stage and even at one point you
have like the mic in the stand and
you're literally like
like it it was like every single bit you
had was like it's like a single topic
that you choreographed this entire world
around i'm just like yeah that's that's
that whole section is about
um
friends
what type of friends do you have yeah so
when i was thinking of that joke i was
thinking of like what type of friends do
people have
you know are they good friends are they
bad friends
um and in life you know
you you
we are able to educate people
you know through laughter like
and when i talk about people's friends
i'm really to you really got to be
careful with friends you hang around and
you got to be careful what you you know
what you bring into your energy
and
so when i go through that it's like you
know i asked them like who came with
they go who came with their friends
that's the first thing i asked and then
you know it's like clapping i say no
i'm not talking about your your fake
friends i'm talking about your real
friends like who came with your real
friends and you can see that second clap
is like yeah i'm with my real friend
yeah big time even if they're not
[Laughter]
and i talk and i go into like you know
about you know when you're driving in a
car if they stay up with you or they go
to sleep
you know are they your real friends so
all of that whole section of 10 minutes
to 12 minutes is just about friends yeah
and what that's what i love about comedy
is how it can bring people together
you know and to develop like the level
you're at now takes years and decades of
you know so you've been doing since
you're 19. so i always ask comics on
here like
what is like a show like a boo story or
like your worst bomb you just never
forget what is that story for you huh
the worst bond oh that sigh that painful
size oh gosh
i have to go
i so i did apollo three
times uh the first time is when i was 19
i did the apollo the day before i did
deaf comedy james my first tv was the
apollo
uh i destroyed it
i knew i was going to destroy the depth
jam because that same set i did on
apollo i did on depth jam
and i knew if it worked on apollo
i it was going to crush on the def
comedy gym
um
so i went back and did the apollo
again and i ripped destroyed it
and the third time that i did the apollo
someone got booed in front of me
and i think somebody like the
a levert or something that's how long
ago leverk was supposed to go up after
the boot
right so steve harvey comes to me he's
like look red
dude just got booed
um
levert's supposed to go on but i'm gonna
put you
on and i'm like
all right i wasn't even ready i was i
was about to go i mean i was ready for
that lever
uh and then go on
so they they put me on and i go out and
say
the dumbest thing that you can ever say
on the apollo i say oh man i see you
guys blowing people out here
y'all can boo me you know i don't care
before i can get the i don't care how
the booze started
and i tried to fight the bull i tried to
come back from the boo
it was just nothing that i can do to
come back from that boot
and i mean i didn't get a joke out
i didn't say nothing other than
oh you guys are out here booming people
oh yeah i can boo boo hoo i'm talking
about and uh this is a true story after
i got off stage
i walked directly from the stage out the
if you ever go to apollo it's a red door
at the apollo
i walk straight out that red door and i
walked 110 blocks
[Music]
i walked from 125th street
[Laughter]
down to 15th west
down to 15th street
uh down to lower manhattan it took that
long for me to get it out i mean it's
like
i had to walk away
so far
from the booth to walk away from the
wreckage from the crime scene so that
was right that was the worst set i ever
i mean the worst boo
i've ever had i ever had too many booze
in my life but asking somebody to boo me
was the worst thing and i tell young
comics never ask people to boo you
that's the worst thing you could ever do
yeah we all go through that though i
mean i came up here in atlanta where
they shut the lights off on me before
like i've gotten it all too we all go
through those so that's why i always
have that but it builds character though
for sure you know bill's character i
think that i would be the person that i
am today if i didn't learn that lesson
that night yeah yeah like you never ask
people to do things to you because they
might do it
you know like people you're like you
could kill me i'm like
you know what i ask nobody to do that
beg for your life
but comedy is that powerful it can
invoke those emotions you know
and to see what what you're doing now
with running for mayor i think it's so
important because this is like comedy
education and telling comedian stories
but
for you to take
the comedy skill set of connecting with
people and you're running as an
independent as well which is you just
like want everyone you know which as a
comedian it's like you have to learn how
to entertain everyone you know like if
if i can do jokes in front of all white
audiences that don't work in front of
all black audiences or vice versa then i
just get rid of the joke and your comedy
is funny to everyone so the fact you're
able to start translating that into
actually making an impact beyond just
telling jokes is very inspiring for a
comedian like me 12 years in the game of
like well man
what what else is possible in this game
and what kind of impact can we make i
mean you've been doing this you've
always helped the youth and you've
always been a part of the community and
stuff but to now seeing you do it
running for mayor of dc it's like it's
really inspiring as a comedian to be
like wow there's we can be doing so much
more i mean i think that um
i think we as comedians
have always
been in the political game
i think that we write policies every day
um the subjects that we talk that we
talk about
um the emotions that we bring to this to
a stage
is policy you know i was talking to
someone in my uh my team the other day i
said
before i knew what policy was
i was doing policy and now i know what
policy is it's really
a problem
that's happening
and a solution to solve that problem
right so you you're trying to create
things
that
have problems
or that cause problems in our community
to bring on solutions right
so
when i got the
calling to run for mayor three and a
half years ago
i asked god i was like
run for mayor
um okay how do how am i gonna translate
this and really have people understand
and he said look
you've been a humanitarian all your life
you've been a philanthropist all your
life
you've been a community activist
you've been a person who has
uh
held dc down and
you know i i feel like i have dc on my
back
since i was born with a with a
red-skinned blanket on my back
i feel like
i've been repping this city
so
when it comes to
being able to make that that's that
pivot
you know people like was it was it hard
i'm like
it wasn't really it's not hard for me to
make pivots because
i pivoted into comedy
you know i was playing football i was
you know had a full scholarship i played
with shannon sharp and you know we were
all like
you know young young men just
pivoting
you know when i was a singer when i was
young my mom's put me in all these
choirs
um i pivoted into it and something else
so i never allow people to
really box me into what i want to pivot
into especially when you know
you're moving with the winds i call it
you're moving with you know the god
spirit
and i think that dc deserves someone
uh like myself
that represents the people
in real life
to come in and have a voice for them
and who can touch everybody all people
you know
when i decided to run independent they
was like well you know you're a democrat
i'm like yeah i'm a democrat but
i'm also independent i'm independently
you know moving through this world
and i don't want anybody to just
party line politic me
and i don't want anybody to try to
control me because so many people like
ourselves no matter if you're a democrat
a republican state or whatever green
independent
you're just
independently thinking like this is what
this is uh who i am
and i think sometimes we allow uh
the
government to to control
our movements like you know we live in a
free society right
but we don't think freely sometimes
yeah and i think it's important as just
thinking of like comedians and there's
people who do like political jokes and
things like that and bring light to that
and even we've talked about like cat
williams the material he's done that
years later is still even more relevant
than it was several years ago
it's like what what else do you think
comedians can be doing to like either
use our platform or really like take
take what you're doing and really start
making like an actual impact not just
talking about it and whatnot but like
what what can comedians do to even think
beyond just like these jokes well i
don't i don't really think that we're
comedians um
i don't think that i think we're we're
we're
big public speakers
like i i really don't allow people to
really put me in a comedy box
because for some reason people think
that we're a joke
like we we make people laugh so you feel
like you can say oh he he's a joke
no i'm not no joke and stop playing with
me
you know
oh he went back to dc right there he's
like watch out slim watch us
i mean i mean we work too hard to become
too smart for you to put us in a box
so yeah i'm a public speaker you know i
make people laugh for a living and i
think more people should laugh in life
you know
too many politicians are
tight
and they feel like they have to be this
way
but then they leave the camera and then
they
act the food yeah you know be yourself
yeah and you've been doing you've been
doing like your own movie production
company and things like that it's like
you so you've been
always looking for other things to do
besides one thing you've always seemed
like you've always been pivoting and
looking for different ways to kind of
create success in this game well my film
company um but it's movios
uh
our grant inc red gram productions i've
had i've had i got a lot of companies uh
um red creative well rightful people
uh and i tell people that you can always
expound your your ability to grow like
expound as much as possible you know
even with your show right here you know
this is a national show this is not just
a local show it's national it's actually
international but it's what you push
it's how you push it it push your brand
uh my film company
you know i've been you know when i wrote
my first film family reunion
and i shot in dc in virginia on my i
shot in dc around my old neighborhood
and i shot in virginia on my
grandmother's uh land
that was like the first time i said okay
you can take thought
to theater
you know you could say if you have a
idea i want to make a movie called
family reunion the movie you know let's
start this script let's write it
um and then when i start when i was
working for viacom and producing
television shows over 25 shows for the
viacom network and it was entrusting me
to employ
thousands of people and
work with
millions of dollars in budgets and
i knew then that
god had a mission for me to be a creator
uh when i did the flavor flavor when i
wrote that with flavor flame and it was
just like
oh man
he put me in these positions so i take
every position that i've been put in
super serious and so when it comes to
like running for mayor
i don't allow people
to to put me in that box and
my policies are
something that should be taken super
serious and when we do our forums that's
coming up
uh because they didn't think that it
would come down to me in the current
mayor you know it was a lot of people
you know running for mayor in washington
dc
a lot of great people
um
but at the end of the day i knew it was
going to ultimately come down to me and
her
and on november 8th history will be made
and i will become the first independent
mayor of washington d.c
i have no doubt i i'm i'm inspired man
like what what do you think if i if i
could selfishly ask like this this show
has over 400 interviews with comedians
and we're really trying to spread that
comedy game we're like what what do you
think we could be doing more here like
is there anything any advice you have
for
young guns out here i think that you're
doing it i mean you 400 interviews i
mean that in itself means that you're
dedicated to pulling up on people
and
getting
the people that you want i mean you
reached out to me
you know that means you're a go-getter
that means that you can get anybody that
you really put your mind to and if they
don't want to be on the show hey
there's so many
so many more talented people out there
that god is going to truly
bless you to speak with
and somebody's going to get something
out of every interview you do
and that's the most important part
and i promise you you'll have your own
this this is your production company
this is you know you got two great
people working with you behind the
camera you have yourself and it's set up
properly and you're making the moves
that
that you need to make to to get the
information to the people and that's
that's what counts
you know you know the algorithm is going
to pick up to what the algorithms are
yeah uh and you'll
believe me this interview you start
trending more yeah yeah yeah after this
interview
he sits down with the
future mayor of washington d.c before he
was the mayor
you know and everybody will always look
back at this interview
you know we in the you know the w hotel
and you went and said you know they put
me out of the lobby i'm gonna go rent i
mean i'm gonna go get a room yeah you
know and get this interview done and
that takes that's what it's all about
never letting them stop stop you in your
tracks always fight through the wall
mm-hmm yeah
so as we land this plane here and thank
you so much for your time land of plane
is a great way to say it
so uh this has been a little bit of a
ride and it's been nice i like it man i
like this uh private jet work
it's pj you gotta be
yeah yeah
i don't mind i like it it's not like my
cat waves pj he's another oh you know
no flight attendant but we got it yeah
yeah we're almost here we on the way
help on the way everyone away he's in on
time you know it's propellers but you
know
[Laughter]
so so the thing i always in these
interviews with is like your favorite
comedy advice or the biggest comedy
lesson or just like the biggest yeah
comedy takeaway you can like share from
your career
the biggest takeaway
always be humble
never think that you're bigger than
the moment
write every day
even if it's something small
treat people with respect
love and care
never be afraid to
give up
what you think you need
to get what you're supposed to have
keep moving
cry sometimes
call your friends
love your family
learn something new every day
and uh
never disrespect yourself
amen amen
are you are you getting emotional you
feeling emotional emotional what's
making you emotional
i just think cause uh
when you do like 30 years in a career
and you know
is
ending not you know physically ending
but you know you're moving on to
something else
and
it's gonna be missed
so the moving on apart
not being afraid to move on is the
the part that
gets you emotional
yeah i mean like even me ten years and
during the pandemic it's like oh man
we're never gonna get to do comedy again
but you actually making that pivot of
like it's almost like a higher calling
of like i'm stepping away from this to
step into like the next
like the next version of myself here
yeah i mean you know
pandemic was rough on us
uh
my wife always says you know if you
don't tell jokes for or you don't get on
stage for two weeks you get you get real
weird around the house me too yeah yeah
uh
so
you know stepping all the way away from
it i'm gonna have to have uh some type
of outlet i'm probably gonna start
boxing this
i'm gonna go to the gym every day next
time you see me i'll probably be busting
out this suit
so are you like retiring from like is
this like when you become mayor is it
like i'm never doing comedy again
um
that's that's deep
um i can't you never can say never
mm-hmm
i talked to d.o ugly about this
he said you know don't don't say you
know you're never gonna tell jokes again
but i am
we you know i am stepping down
from
you know my current situation to
focus on
my city
focus on
you know helping the community and
you know
fighting for
um
people
so where can people go and like donate
or like vote or just yeah where can
people go to really support this
movement all right what camera i'm going
to yeah that'll be that'll be the tight
right there all right so
make sure you go to
grant4meddc.com i'm pretty sure they're
going to put it up on the screen but
grant4meddc.com
um and
hit the donate button
volunteer
just get involved with the movement and
any anybody you know in dc
dc area just push it because this thing
is trending right now this is not just a
local race this is a national race that
affects all of us
the policies that are happening in
washington dc are happening around the
country and every major city in the
world so make sure you do that and just
you know
make sure you hit red grants on ig and
you can just follow the whole movement
and shout out to my team team red
and everybody who's been volunteering we
have over 400 something volunteers
and maybe 500 now
and we want to get to a thousand before
november 8th so
make sure you move with the movement and
you don't have to be in dc to actually
be a part of the movement and always one
thing
keep your party
but keep your thoughts independent
thanks boom
and uh maybe maybe while you're looking
at the camera could you say your name
and why people should listen to hot
breath
did this show a little love i was just
man i appreciate that man all right
let's go
so that's your boy red grant and you
gotta listen to hot breath
bruh yeah yeah okay
it just sounds so funny say hot breath
hey we're gonna take two
this your boy red grant and you gotta
look and listen to hot breath because
your breath don't want to be hot and hot
breath is always not good but this one
is great this is the hottest breath that
you like in your life take it all in
[Music]
hot breath
red grant thanks for being on hot breath
my man thank you bro i appreciate